it's okay great we talked about OpenCog
which is kind of one the software
framework but also the actual attempt to
build an AGI system and then there is
this exciting idea of singularity net so
maybe can you say first what is
singularity net sure sure
singularity net is a platform for
realizing it decentralized network of
artificial intelligences so Marvin
Minsky the AI pioneer who I knew a
little bit he had the idea of a society
of minds like you should achieve in AI
not by writing one algorithm or one
program but he should put a bunch of
different a eyes out there and the
different a eyes will interact with each
other each playing their own role and
then the totality of the society of a
eyes would would be the thing that
displayed the human level intelligence
and I had when he was alive had many
debates with would Marvin about about
this idea and he I think he really
thought the mind was more like a society
than I do like I I think I think you
could have a mind that was as
disorganized as a human society but I
think a human-like mind has a bit more
central control than that actually like
I mean we have this thalamus and the
medulla and limbic system we have a sort
of top-down control system that guides
much of much of what we do more so than
this society does so I think he
stretched that metaphor a little too far
but but I also think there's there's
something interesting there and so in
the in the 90s when I started my first
sort of non-academic AI project web mind
which was an AI start up in New York in
the Silicon our alley area in the late
90s when I was aiming to do there was
make a distribute Society of ai's the
different parts of which would live on
different computers all around the world
and each one would do its own thinking
about the data
but they would all share information
with each other and outsource work with
each other and cooperate and the
intelligence would be in the whole
collective and I organized a conference
together with Frances huiling in at free
university of brussels in 2001 which was
the global brain zero conference and
where we're planning the next version
the global brain one conference at the
free university of brussels for next
year two thousand twenty one twenty two
twenty years after then we maybe we can
have the next one ten years after that I
get exponentially faster until the
singularity comes with that seems right
yeah yeah yeah so the idea with the
global brain was you know maybe the AI
won't just be in a program one guy's
computer but the AI will be you know in
the internet as a whole with the
cooperation of different AI modules
living in different places so one of the
issues you face when architecting a
system like that is you know how is the
whole thing controlled do you have like
a centralized control unit that pulls
the puppet strings of all the different
modules there or do you have a
fundamentally decentralized network
where the Society of a eyes is
controlled in some democratic and self
organize what about all the AIS in in
that society right and Francis and I had
different view of many things but we
both we both wanted to make like a
global society of AI minds with a
decentralized organizational mode now
the main difference was he wanted the
individual a eyes to be all incredibly
simple and all the intelligence to be on
the collective level whereas I thought
that was cool but I felt a more
practical way to do it might be if some
of the agents in the Society of Minds
were fairly generally intelligent on
their own so like you could have a bunch
of open cogs out there and a bunch of
simpler learning systems and then these
are all cooperating coordinating
together sort of like in the brain okay
the brain as a whole is the general
intelligence but some parts of the
cortex you could say have a fair bit of
general intelligence on their own
whereas a part of the cerebellum or
limbic system have very little general
intelligence on their own and they're
contributing to general intelligence you
know by way of the connectivity to other
other modules do you see instantiation
of the same kind of you know maybe
different versions of OpenCog but also
just the same version OpenCog and maybe
many associations yeah yeah that's part
yeah that's what David and Hertz and I
wanna do with many Sofia and other
robots yeah yeah each one has its own
individual mind living on the server but
there's also a collective intelligence
infusing them and a part of the mountain
living on the edge in each robot all
right yeah so so that the thing is at
that time as well as web mind being
implemented in Java 1.1 as like a
massive distributed system yeah the you
know the the blockchain wasn't there yet
so how them do this decentralized
control you know we sort of knew it we
knew about distributed systems we knew
about encryption so I mean we had the
key principles of what underlies
blockchain now but I mean we didn't put
it together in the way that's been done
now so when when Vitalik beuter and then
colleagues came out with aetherium
blockchain you know many many years
later like 2013 or something then that
was like well this is interesting
like this is so ID scripting language
it's kind of dorky in a way and I don't
see why you need a turing-complete
language for this purpose but on the
other hand this is like the first time I
could sit down and start to like script
infrastructure for decentralized control
of the eyes in this society of minds in
the tract of a while like you could hack
the Bitcoin code base but it's really
annoying worse solidity is is aetherium
scripting language is just nicer and
easier to use I'm very annoyed with it
by this point but like Java I mean these
languages are amazing when it when they
first come out so then I came up with
the idea that turned into singularity
that okay let's let's make a
decentralized agent system where a bunch
of different ai's you know wrapped up
and say different docker containers or
LXE containers different a eyes can each
of them have their own identity on the
blockchain and the coordination of this
community of AIS has no central
controller
dictator right they can't ruin there's
no central repository of information the
coordination of the Society of Mines is
done entirely by the decentralized
Network and in a decentralized way by by
the algorithms right because you know
the model of Bitcoin is in math we trust
right and so that that's what you need
you need the society of minds to trust
only in math not trust only in once one
centralized servers are the AI systems
themselves outside of them yeah Jim but
then the communication at the moment
yeah yeah we I would have loved to put
the ai's operations on chain in some
sense but in etherium it's just too slow
you can't you can't you can't somehow
it's the basic communication between our
systems that's basically an AI is just
some software in single areas just some
software process living in the container
and as input now there's a proxy that
lives in that container along with the
AI that handles the interaction with the
rest of singularity net and then when
one AI wants to contribute with another
one in the network they set up a number
of channels and the set up of those
channels uses the ethereum blockchain
god once the channels are set up then
data flows along those channels without
without having to be having to be on the
blockchain
all the girls in the blockchain is the
fact that some data went along that
channel so you can do so there's not a
shared knowledge it's well the the
identity of each agent is on the
blockchain right on the ethereum
blockchain
if one agent rates the reputation of
another agent that goes on the
blockchain and agents can published what
API is they won't fulfill on the on the
blockchain but the actual data for AI
and there is or not is not do you think
it could be do you think it should be um
in some cases it should be in some cases
maybe it shouldn't be but I mean III
think that I'll give you an example
using aetherium you can't do it using
now there's more modern and faster block
chains where you could you could start
to do that in in in in some cases two
years ago that was less so it's very
rapidly evolving ecosystem so like one
example maybe
you can comment on something I worked a
lot on is autonomous vehicles you can
see each individual vehicle as a a I
system and you can see vehicles from
Tesla for example and then Ford and GM
and all these is also like a larger I
mean they all are running the same kind
of system on each sets of vehicles
so it's individual AI systems and
individual vehicles but it's all
different stations is the same AI system
within the same company so you know you
can envision a situation where all of
those AI systems are put on singularity
net right yeah and how how do you see
that happening and what would be the
benefit and could they share data I get
I guess the biggest things is that the
power there's in a decentralized control
but the benefit would have been is is
really nice if they can somehow share
the knowledge in an open way if they
choose to yeah yeah yeah those are all
quite good points so I think the the
benefit from being on the on the
decentralized network as we envision it
is that we want the AIS in the network
to be outsourcing work to each other and
making API calls to each other
frequently about you so the real benefit
would be if that a I wanted to outsource
some cognitive processing or data
processing or data pre-processing
whatever to some other ai's in the
network which specialize in something
different and this this really requires
a different way of thinking about AI
software development right so just like
object-oriented programming that's
different than imperative programming
and now object or numbers all use these
frameworks to do things rather than just
libraries even you know shifting to
agent based programming where AI agent
is asking other like live real-time
evolving agents for feedback and what
they're doing that's a different way of
thinking I mean it's it's not a new one
there was loads of papers on agent based
programming in the 80s in homeward but
if you're willing to shift to an agent
based
development then you can put less and
less in your AI and rely more and more
on interactive calls to other a is
running in the network and of course
that's not fully manifested yet because
although we've rolled out a nice working
version of single earning that platform
there's there's only fifty two hundred a
eyes running in there now there's not
tens of thousands of AI so we don't have
the critical mass for the whole society
of mind to be doing doing what what we
want what we have the magic really
happens when that's just a huge number
of agents yeah yeah exactly exactly in
terms of data we're partnering closely
with another blockchain project called
ocean protocol an ocean protocol that's
the project of Trent McConkey who
developed big chain DB which is a
blockchain based database so ocean
protocol is basically block chain based
Big Data and aims at making it efficient
for four different AI processes or
statistical processes or whatever to to
share large datasets or one process can
send a clone of itself to work on the
other guys data set and send results
back and so forth so by getting ocean
and and you know that you have data like
so this is the data ocean right so again
by getting ocean and singularity net to
to interoperate we're aiming to aiming
to take into account of the big data
aspect also it but it's it's quite
challenging because to build this whole
decentralized blockchain based
infrastructure I mean your competitors
are like Google Microsoft Alibaba and
Amazon which have so much money to put
behind their centralized infrastructures
plus the sovereign simpler algorithmic
problems because making it centralized
in some ways is is is easier right so
right there they're very major computer
science challenges and I think what what
you saw with the whole ICO boom in the
blocking cryptocurrency world is a lot
of young hackers who were hacking
Bitcoin or aetherium and they see well
why don't we make this decentralized on
blockchain then after they raised some
money through and ICO they realized how
hard it is like I actually were
wrestling with incredibly hard Computer
Science
software engineering and distributed
systems problems which can be solved but
they're just very difficult to solve and
in some cases the individuals who
started those projects we're not we're
not well equipped to actually solve the
problems that so you think would you say
that's the main bottleneck if if you
look at the future of currency you know
the question is well currency the main
bottleneck is politics like it's
government so in the fans of armed thugs
that will shoot you if you bypass their
that currency restriction that's right
so like your senses that versus the
technical challenges because you kind of
just suggested the technical challenges
are quite high as well for making it
distributed money you could do that on
Algar and right now I mean so that while
etherium is too slow there's Algar and
then there's a few other more modern
more scalable blockchains it would work
fine for a decentralized global global
currency right so I think there weren't
technical bottlenecks to that two years
ago and maybe aetherium 2.0 will be as
fast as out there and III don't know
that that's not that's not fully written
yet right so yeah I think the obstacle
to currency being put on the blockchain
is that there's the other stuff you
might see won't be on the blockchain you
know just be on the blockchain in a way
that enforces centralized control and
government hegemony rather than
otherwise like that er MV will probably
the first global the first currency on
the blockchain the e ruble maybe next
already be ruble I mean this hilarious
digital currency you know makes total
sense but they would rather do it in the
way that Putin and Xi Jinping have
access to the the global keys for
everything right then so and then the
analogy to that in terms of singularity
net I mean there's echoes I think you've
mentioned before that Linux gives you
hope yeah it's not as heavily regulated
as money right yes right not yet
oh that's a lot slip for your the money
too right I mean money is is easier to
regulate because it's kind of easier to
define where's AI is it's almost
everywhere inside everything what
where's the boundary between AI and
software right I mean if you're going to
regulate AI
there's no IQ test for every hardware
device it has a learning algorithm
you're gonna be putting like hegemonic
regulation on all software and I don't
rule out that that any doubt just soft
and huh yeah how do you tell if
software's adapt to him what's up every
software is gonna be adaptive or maybe
they may be the you know maybe we're
living in the Golden Age of open source
that we'll know that will not always be
open maybe it'll become centralized
control software by golly it is entirely
possible and part of what I think we're
doing with things like singularity net
protocol is creating a toolset that can
be used to counteract that sort of thing
say a similar thing about mesh
networking right plays a minor role now
the ability to access internet like
directly phone to phone on the other
hand if your government starts trying to
control your use of the internet
suddenly having mesh working mesh
networking there it can be very
convenient right and so right now
something like a decentralized
blockchain based AGI framework or narrow
AI framework it's cool it's it's nice to
have on the other end if governments
start trying to tamp down on my AI
interoperating with someone's AI in in
Russia or somewhere right then suddenly
having a decentralized protocol that
nobody owns or controls becomes an
extremely valuable part of the toolset
and you know we've we've put that out
there now it's not perfect but it but it
it operates and you know it's pretty
blockchain agnostic so we're talking to
Algar and about making part of single
around on al Guren my good friend to
FISA liebe has a cool blockchain project
called toda which is a blockchain
without a distributed ledger it's like a
whole other architecture so there's so
that there's a lot of more advanced
things you can do in the blockchain
world singularity net could be ported
and to a whole bunch of it could be made
multi chain important to a whole bunch
of different block chains and there's
there's a lot of potential and a lot of
importance to putting this
kind of toolset out there if you compare
the OpenCog what you could see is
OpenCog allows tight integration of a
few AI algorithms that share the same
knowledge store in in real time in RAM
right
singularity net allows loose integration
of multiple different ai's they can
share knowledge but they're mostly not
going to be sharing knowledge in RAM and
I'm on the same machine and I think what
we're gonna have is a network of network
of networks right like I mean you have
the knowledge graph and inside inside
the the open cog system and then you
have a network of machines inside
distributed OpenCog mind but then that
OpenCog will interface with other AIS
doing deep neural nets or custom biology
data analysis or whatever they're doing
in singularity net which is a looser
integration of different AR some of
which maybe maybe they're they're their
own networks right and I think at a very
loose analogy you could see that in the
human body like the brain has regions
like cortex or hippocampus which tightly
interconnected like Chronicle columns
with it within the cortex for example
then there's looser connection than the
different lobes at the brain and then
the brain interconnects with the
endocrine system in different parts of
the body even even more loosely then
your body interacts even more loosely
with the other one other people that you
talk to so you often have networks where
the networks within networks with
progressively looser coupling as you get
get higher up in that hierarchy I mean
you have that in biology of it in the in
the Internet and as a just networking
medium and I think I think that's what
we're gonna have in the network of
software processes leading to to AGI
that's a beautiful way to see the world
again the same similar question is with
OpenCog if somebody wanted to build an
AI system and plug into the singularity
net what would you recommend like yeah
that's oh that's much easier I mean
OpenCog is still a research system so it
takes some expertise
sometimes we have tutorials but it's
it's somewhat cognitively
labor-intensive to get up to speed on
OpenCog and i mean what's one of the
things we hope to change with the true
AGI OpenCog 2.0 version is just make
make the learning curve more similar to
tensorflow or torch or something RIT
right now OpenCog is amazingly powerful
but but not simple too not simple to do
one on the other hand singularity net
you know as a open platform was
developed a little more with usability
in mind over the blockchain is still
kind of a pain so I mean I mean if
you're a command-line guy there's a
command-line interface it's quite easy
to you know take any AI that has an API
and lives in the docker container and
put it online anywhere and then it joins
the global singularity net and anyone
who puts a request for services out into
the singular yet the period appeared
discovery mechanism will find your your
AI and if it does what what was asked it
will it can then start a conversation
with your AI about whether it wants to
ask your AI to do something for it how
much it would cost and so on so that
that's that's fairly simple if you wrote
an AI and want it listed on like
official singularity net marketplace
which is not which is on our website
then we have a publisher portal and then
there's a kyc process to go through
because then we have some legal
liability for what goes on on that
website so that in a way that's been an
education to there's sort of two layers
like there's the open decentralized
protocol and there's the market yeah
anyone can use the open decentralized
protocol yeah so say some developers
from Iran then there's brilliant AI guys
and University of Isfahan and Tehran
they can put this stuff on singularity
in that protocol and just like they can
put something on the internet right I
don't control it but if we're going to
list something on the singularity net
marketplace and put a little picture and
a link to it yeah then if I put some
Iranian AI geniuses code on there then
Donald Trump can send a bunch of
jackbooted thugs to my house to arrest
me for doing business with Iran so so I
mean we already see in some ways the
value of having a decentralized protocol
because what I hope is that someone in
Iran will put online
an Iranian singularity in the
marketplace right which you can pay in
the cryptographic token which is not
owned by any country and then if you're
in like Congo or somewhere that doesn't
have any problem with Iran
you can subcontract AI services that you
find on that marketplace right even
though you US citizens can't but by US
law so right now that's kind of a minor
point you know as you eluded if if
regulations go in the wrong direction it
could become more of a major point but I
think it also is the case that having
these workarounds to regulations in
place is a defense mechanism against
those regulations being put into place
and you can see that in the music
industry right I mean Napster just
happened and BitTorrent just happened
and now most people in my kids
generation they're baffled by the idea
of paying for music my dad pays for
music I mean yeah but because these
decentralized mechanisms happened and
then the regulations followed right and
the regulations would be very different
if they'd been put into place before
there was not stir and BitTorrent and so
forth so in the same way we got to put
AI out there in a decentralized vein and
big data out there in a decentralized
vein now so that the most advanced AI in
the world is fundamentally decentralized
and if that's the case that's just the
reality the regulators have to deal with
and then as in the music case they're
going to come up with regulations that
sort of work with it with the
decentralized reality beautiful
you